Eli Barak, thank you so much
for joining me.
How are you?
Good, how are you?
I'm great.
It's so fantastic to have you.
We know each other
for quite some time now,
for quite a few years.
All the way back from the robotics team
when you so generously came
and helped mentor our team,
a relatively rookie team.
And you've built some
really incredible, incredible
projects and mentorship
in ... Emek Hefer
and ...
So, tell me a little bit
about your journey.
Where do you come from
and how do you do that transition
from an entrepreneur and investor
to education and mentorship?
Yeah, so first of all,
thank you for having me.
I think that probably the best definition
is to say that I'm a serial entrepreneur.
Started in the software market
in the Israeli army.
Found myself focusing on software.
My first startup ...
first exit
was in the CRM EOP markets.
Moved to the states,
lived in the US for five years
with my family.
Came back to Israel
just before 9/11.
And decided that I need to find something
interesting to do once retired,
because the exit was good enough.
And after 18 months of doing nothing
and going to coffee shops,
you need to figure out
that you do want to do something.
And I found myself,
by coincidence I must say,
working with high school kids.
And robotics is an interesting platform
not necessarily because the kids
will eventually focus on robotics
in their adult life, but rather
because it's a combination
of different disciplines including
mechanical engineering,
software, system engineering,
working in a team,
understanding and handling priorities.
So modern robotics, in a way,
is a great platform if you want
to work with kids
and start some kind of an excitement in them
to be part of the technology
market or technology world.
And this is basically what it is.
It's a trigger.
But Eli, before we get
deeper into the robotics,
I have to understand,
because most people who end up devoting
over 100% time towards
education and mentorship, they often come
from those types of backgrounds
that they've done that
for quite some time.
You're coming in as an entrepreneur,
investor, serial entrepreneur,
and you're saying all of a sudden
devoting 100% of your time
or 150% of your time to help mentor kids.
So, how does that work?
First of all, 100% or 120%
is a relative definition.
If you want, you have 26 hours a day
and you find time to do
things that you like. I kept doing,
and I'm still doing, a lot of work
with entrepreneurs, adult entrepreneurs.
What you find out and what attracted me
to work also with high school kids
is that, if you think about it,
this is the next generation.
You talk about the millennials now.
Even if they are now 15, 16 years old,
in 10 years they are
the next generation entrepreneurs.
So, even if you are focused
on entrepreneurs and startups
and you are looking
for the next generation,
you find yourself talking to kids.
They are very intuitive, very innovative.
So, I think that what you find out
when you work with kids
around those areas of innovation
and out of the box thinking is that
you can get great results
when you have mixed teams
of adults and kids.
And this is where I started ...
I can say that now about, what
20 years later,
I came back to Israel 20 years ago,
back from the states. 20 years later,
and now I'm working
with a lot of startups
that are combining,
and we talk about it later,
combining kids and adults.
It's a great combination,
because you have great ideas
coming from them.
Yeah, they are less mature of course.
They don't have all the
professional skills you are looking for.
In the same time,
they are very, very innovative
and are still capable of thinking
out of the box,
something that we are losing
as we are aging
and getting a profession.
Right.
And this is very interesting
for the ecosystem in Israel.
And we find,
I can point out now five companies
in the hub that we are running
in Emek Hefer where we have kids,
11 and 12th graders
that are part of those startups
just because they met each other
and are now involved.
Right. 100%
And I'd love to understand
a little bit better about this community
that you're building there.
So, what you're doing with Emek Hefer
is not what an ordinary robotics team
does in Israel or all over the world.
And it's gone beyond simply the six week
first robotics competition, right?
It's gone much beyond that.
So Eli, talk to me a little bit about
what is the community
within this education sphere
like FIRST...
and what you're doing there,
and then talk to me about
what you're doing outside
of just the FIRST program.
Sure. So, again, it's not a secret
that the traditional
formal education system,
the school system, is not working
or not working very good.
Now, with the covid-19 days
make it even more difficult
for that system.
But kids are looking
for something interesting to do.
Everybody is bored.
The typical answer you get
from a typical high school kid
that is coming back from school
and, "How was your day?"
And the answer is "boring"
or "okay" is the best you can get.
Like a very shallow okay.
And the idea was to try to build
some kind of an ecosystem that we
first of all, and before everything else,
will reignite, if you want, people
and make them excited
about their daily operations.
So, the whole idea was to create
some kind of an ecosystem,
some kind of an environment
where people could be excited
about ... are doing.
Put aside their age,
whether they are kids or adults.
And since I'm involved
for 30 something years in technology
and in the startup ecosystem,
we said, and we, me together
with another partner,
his name is Liran.
And we are partners here in Israel.
Both of us are coming separately,
but coming from the high tech sector.
And the idea was to create
some kind of a local,
if you want, domestic ecosystem
that will be part
of the community at large
if you want.
So, it's not only your neighborhood,
but it's the area around you.
I would say 20, 30, 40,
50 thousand people in that area.
Emek Hefer is an example.
The Hefer Valley here in Israel.
And try to bring content
or create an enabling platform
around entrepreneurship, innovation,
out of the box thinking,
not necessarily technology,
but technology is a great start
for many of those.
Put everything in place,
which means content, lectures,
you name it, put it there.
And allow them to consume, if you want,
the content and the place
and everything you put ... for them
when they need it and develop themselves.
So, we are mentoring
and we provide the space,
if you want, a hybrid solution
because it's a combination
of an open space, like we work together
with an accelerator
and a venture fund,
and we do all of those together.
But not in a predefined program that says,
"Well, welcome to our accelerator.
You have two years
and half a million dollars.
At the end, you need to be able
to fly or you crash"
Sometimes it works,
most of the times it doesn't work.
And the idea here
was to try and create the platform.
So, platform is a place to be.
Offices, maker space, C and C,
and you name it.
Everything that you need
to really make things
and not only think about them
if you want to do it.
Bring a lot of content from leading ideas
and CEOs of companies
that are coming and talking
to the future entrepreneurs
in different areas.
Do mentoring
and really bring mentors
that could take them forward.
And have a venture fund
to do small early stage
pre-seed, if you want, investments.
All of that is aiming now not only adults,
the usual entrepreneurs, but also kids.
Right.
Try to mix them.
I don't know how you call it in the US,
but in Israel, we have this spot
that you do like a ...
Yeah.
So, I don't know what's the terminology,
probably the same way.
A melting pot, yeah.
So, this is the best description
of what we're trying to do.
You put in a lot of good materials,
good people, mentoring, location,
you do it very slowly.
You need to be,
not to try to expedite things.
You rather need to do it slowly,
and you start to see the community
really building in front of you.
And I can say that now,
in Emek Hefer here, three years later,
we have really a full place.
We have a waiting list of 10, 15 people
that are trying to join,
and we don't have any offices for them.
We have more than a hundred kids,
high school kids, that are involved
in any given ... today.
Yeah. More than a hundred.
Probably next year,
we are going to have more.
Covid-19 created a situation that,
as I said, school is boring.
Schools are now cooperating with us
and saying,
"Well, maybe the informal education
is not so bad, and it's interesting."
And they cooperate with us.
- Wow.
I'm really curious about
what do you see in that space?
So, when you take high schoolers,
and I'm a huge advocate of this myself,
but you take high schoolers
and you give them a different purpose
that's intrinsic, informal education,
that they actually get to build something
and provide a product given,
execute it on what they are learning.
What do you see
outside of the lab?
Do they change at all?
Are they more confident
in different areas?
So, great question.
I would say that the main,
think about it as a toolbox,
and you basically equip them
with a new toolbox for life.
I would say that 90% of the value
that we provide to those high school kids
is not technical at all.
It has nothing to do with robotics
or space or other areas
that we are supporting;
it's rather on a personal toolkit
of how to be part of a team,
how to integrate things, it doesn't matter
what kind of integration.
What we call system engineering,
processes, understanding of
how do you really manage
personal priorities.
And one of the interesting feedbacks
we are getting from kids
and from their teachers in school is that
once they finish the first year
here in our program,
they're coming back to school
and everything in school
is very, very easy for them.
Really?
Yeah. They easily handle the timeline
and they do the tests,
and usually the grades are going up
although they spend
about half of their time here.
They are spending afternoons and nights
and the weekend,
and you need to really push them back out
because if it's up to them,
they spend every minute here.
It's a community for them.
So, all the friendships and everything.
It's like a youth movement, if you want,
which, by the way, is something
we are doing right now in Israel
with the Ministry of Education
and Ministry of Science,
turning all that type of operation
into a recognized youth movement.
It's going to be called Nesher,
which in Hebrew stands for
...
which is youth, something robotics
- Something robotics
And the whole idea is
to really recognize the fact
it is a youth movement
with everything involved.
So, personal skill sets, what they call
the 21st century skill sets,
is the best value they are getting.
Interesting to say that we see
a lot of activities around us
from different, the Ministry of Education,
the IDF, the Israeli Army,
are looking for those kids
not because they know how to do robotics,
but they are much more mature
in their understanding of how to work in a team.
We do find a lot of situations
where kids that were not the best ones
in high school are finding things
to really excel and do things here
and be leaders in different areas.
We work a lot with girls
and fighting very successfully
the situation where girls are not getting
into technology for different reasons.
This is not an Israeli problem,
it's a worldwide one.
Very successfully working with girls,
and really have mixed groups
working with different parts
of the Israeli society.
Charedim that are not really
into technology, and we are doing
very well with them as well
through the few connections we have.
So, the whole idea is using technology.
We are doing it especially with two,
if you want, programs or titles,
one of them you mentioned
which is robotics
and the FIRST organization.
The other one
is something that is developing
all over the world now
which is what is called the new space
or commercial space, applications
that are trying to or starting to look at space
not only as an
intelligence government type of area,
but rather commercial
or private sector that are looking
into those areas.
A lot of startups in Israel in this area.
We are using it
to attract kids to come to us.
So, we have now a mouse,
a simulator that we are building here,
in Emek Hefer, together with the kids
that are going, that is going to have
like an underground lava type
of whatever, and you're going to
have a mission to Mars
and a control room.
The whole idea is really trigger them,
bring them in. Once they are in,
we get them.
100%. But Eli I have to ask,
so at the end of the day,
you're running these programs,
but how do you do this at scale, right?
So as an entrepreneur,
serial entrepreneur and investor,
it's all about you create the value,
you find a product market fit,
you create an amazing experience,
now how do you replicate this
all over the world?
Because I'm convinced.
I went through some of these programs
with you, with your mentorship.
I know how incredible it is
and the tools that it gave me,
but how do you get every kid in the world
to have this experience?
So, it's a great question,
and it's a question
that we started asking ourselves
about three years ago
when we started the first location
here in Emek Hefer,
and we are six partners.
All of us, by the way,
are coming from the high tech sector.
So, this is not real estate for us.
The real estate part
is just an enabling platform.
And this was exactly
the question that we're asking,
"Is this operation some kind of
a one man or two man
or five man operation and that's it?
Or can you really replicate?
Can you really scale?"
It took us two and a half years
to really examine the model,
refine it if you want.
About a year ago, we started to work
on our second location
up in Emek Israel ...
We are now working on it,
building the new location over there
that will be location number two.
Hopefully we open around Pesach,
spring of 2021.
Wow.
We are already talking
about a third location
that is going to be somewhere
around Rehovot,
so little bit south of Tel Aviv.
The whole idea is to do it
outside of the big cities.
Do it in areas where people are looking,
you have good community,
high skills on one hand,
but people that are bored
or looking for interesting things to do.
And you could provide,
since you are out of the big city,
real estate is cheaper,
so you could do things
that you cannot do in Tel Aviv
or in major locations.
Like Emek Izrael now is going to be
all around space, and we are building now
a new planetarium
over the really sophisticated,
special telescope
that is a sun telescope.
So, not only a regular one.
A lot of development around this.
In Emek Hefer we do a lot
of robotics and agriculture,
which is something we could do here
because we have tons of areas around us,
and ...
are the easiest thing to do.
And yeah, I think that I would say,
even on something which is important,
you learn very early that if you want
to have this smoothly working,
it cannot be based on philanthropy.
It must be a business model.
Now, why is that?
Why do you think that is?
Because long term,
it's very easy to get donations, funds
to build something,
but it's basically impossible
to keep getting those donations
to operate it.
Right.
So, you must, in a way,
come with a plan
that will be not only sustainable,
and fund itself, but be profitable.
Otherwise,
you don't have the funds you need
to really do the investments
at the beginning.
And this is exactly ...
It took us about two years
to make sure that we understand
how to make it profitable.
Now, don't get me wrong,
profitable while still understanding
that there are impact aspects
for your investment.
Community is important,
so it's not only maximizing
the return of the investment
in terms of funding and money,
it's also in community value.
The model needs to be sustainable,
it needs to be profitable,
and once you do,
you could do whatever you want.
And very interesting to say
another thing, the government,
the different agencies,
and I'm not blaming them,
are never first adopters.
They are not.
They tend to join in later
if you could prove that what you're doing
is really working and sustainable
and bringing value.
Right.
Once you do, they're eager to join,
because this is a success
and they could ...
And I'm not cynical.
What I want to say is that
this is the way it works.
Yeah.
So, once you do it,
I met yesterday the minister of science,
Yizhar Shai, and he came to Emek Izrael
to see what we are building over there.
And now the Ministry of Science
is supportive, and we are getting money
for different things we want to do.
But this is only after we proved
that we are able to bring money,
do what we need, or in a way
we just ...
... say about banks,
the bank wants to lend you money
only when you don't need it.
So, in a way, similar here.
You need to be on your own,
be able to support your ideas,
and prove that it's working.
Everybody else will join you later on,
which is fine.
Eli, this is insightful and inspiring.
I just love what you're doing there,
and I have no doubt
that it'll continue to scale.
And I know the impact
that you personally had on me
and Emek Hefer,
and the ... had on myself
and my friends,
and I'm watching everybody also
in the ... where I served.
I pretty much recognize everybody
from these amazing community,
and it really is a youth movement
just around technology
less about camping.
It's a different youth movement.
Eli, before we go, I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Yeah, this is always interesting
to look back and think about it.
I would say probably
I'm very focused in everything I do,
and people that are working with me
know it. Some kind of a combination,
I usually say that I'm a tall person.
I'm not very tall, not at all,
but tall in the sense of
your head needs to be up in the sky.
You need to be a visionary.
You need to think about big things,
envision in long term, otherwise
you don't have really your direction
and the big picture.
In the same time, you need to be
very connected to the ground.
You're feet need to be
well connected to the ground
and need to be into the details.
There is a phrase that somebody used
that says:
"Think big and act small"
I really believe in this.
I think that we need to,
and I'm trying to be strategical,
think strategy in everything I'm doing,
which I think is a good combination
to describe me.
Some kind of emphasis on strategy
together with very practical
approach to life,
and I believe that the combination
is what makes it not only interesting,
but I will allow myself to say successful.
Eli, toda raba raba.
This is wonderful, and I can't wait
to come visit the greater space.
And it's just incredible
the work that you're doing.
So, thank you very, very much.
My pleasure.
Thank you.